how do i take counsel from my own heart
how do i listen to my higher self
you can't be an artist and worry about
what other people think how is that
possible
oh well you can't be a person to worry
about what other people think and you
certainly can't be an artist and worry
about what other people think
you know
if you track this
you know why do we worry about what
other people think
i think you could probably take it back
to
your earliest
sensation that someone was judging you
and it was very painful we find it very
painful when people judge us so you know
if that happened when you were very very
little and you're very you know artists
are very very sensitive
so you know it happens when they're
little and they have that then they're
going to worry about what other people
think of them certainly in puberty your
body is changing you know you don't
understand often every once in a while
someone goes through puberty looking
beautiful but for the most of us you
know you're getting braces and you're
not your most beautiful time of life
and you know we worry about what people
think of us and then we go into high
school which is freaking brutal brutal
place
it's not natural it's not where anyone
should i mean high school today is just
like craziness but anyway
you go into high school and you're
trying desperately to find a group
somewhere to belong someone to have
lunch with
and you worry about what people think of
you
if you try to create from that
impossible
that is impossible there is no creating
when you're worried about what other
people think of you because you will try
to create things that will make them
like you and that's what actors do in
auditions and they don't book the part
because they go on the audition they go
i do this thing that i think that you
want me to do and that way i'll get the
part i'll do what i think you want and
then i'll get the part
none of that can happen the whole
purpose
of art is to to to
show the path you know what is the next
path we're always artists are always
looking for the new
the new movement where's the new
direction you know the beatles whole new
direction of music we had a renaissance
really in the 70s painting and music and
dance and twilia thorpe you know
she put ballet and
and musical theater together and jazz
and came out with something nobody had
ever seen before and beach boys music
you know was like nobody had ever seen
dancers move like that before you know
painters in the 70s nobody seen
paintings like that before we don't we
don't have that right now we don't have
any new what is the new what is the
forward movement what is the new way
what is the dow the way
and uh
part of that i think is that we're
living in a really judgmental society
and artists put things out and everybody
feels like they're a critic and
and they're mean and they're really mean
so
you can't care about that
you know even more importantly you can't
care about that because you have to set
an example for those people you have to
not judge those people but say poor
people
don't know where that's coming from but
it's really nasty i'm glad i'm not going
around getting my jollies by knocking
people online you know what i mean poor
people
let's just set an example
um
the way not to care about
what other people think of you is to
have confidence
that you take counsel from your own
heart
so that goes back to how do i take
counsel from my own heart how do i
listen to my higher self
how do i find that same counsel i had at
eight years old when i said why not they
don't see me i'm sad and they said well
we might have to be enough get over it
it was a very matter of fact get over it
we might have to be enough you're
blessed
you know oh okay
okay i don't think it solved it
completely but all of these things we
have to practice
so we have to we have to recognize oh i
really am caring what that person thinks
of me i think i'll let that go
you know
so first we have to recognize it
that takes a little separation that
takes creating a little space so you
can look at you the personality so you
the being can look at you this
personality we work so hard on these
personalities and we think they're great
but trust me you're not your personality
you're something so much bigger so so
much bigger
so once you know that you connect to
that and you can listen
to that you can ask questions you can
listen you can get to come in a state
and ask questions and wait for your
heart to beat on the answer so that
higher consciousness inspiration can
come into that space you're not going to
care what people think about after after
you experience that and you live
intentionally from that oh this came in
i'm really excited i know what my
purpose is i'm going to move in that
direction here are the steps i can take
are you really condemning me
sorry don't have time i hope your life
gets better
you know what i mean
you move forward but
but it is that faith that you are on the
right path
and that you can continue on the right
path because you have certain practices
that will support that
that will take you to a space of
i don't care
what others think of me i'm don't worry
it's not that you don't care so you
don't worry about it
you said something wonderful in the book
too something to the effect of we're
rarely as bad as we think and as great
as we think
and that was that's a really freeing
thought
yeah it is because you know actors they
think they're the best they get it right
they get a great thing and then they
they're like all charged you know they
think i'm cool i'm great i did that work
it's really good you know i'm great
and and they talk about their talent my
talent my talent i go oh okay that's
good
and then the problem is that that they
die from that the minute they they fall
from grace they fall from that to the
depths of oh my god i don't know what
i'm doing and i'm crabby and nobody
likes me and i'll never work again
you know my father was an actor oh my
god every time he was out of a job it
was like i'm never going to work again i
mean they fall
into this depressive state
and so i used to tell my actually i
gotta tell you something
you're never as great as you think you
are you know when you're like pumping
yourself up and feeling like i'm hot
[ __ ] you know guess what
there's somebody else who's hot or [ __ ]
out there you know what i mean and
you're never as bad as you think you are
so you're somewhere in the middle in the
middle stop
measuring it because it's a distraction
to measure
you know
your time is like a bank account
you only have so much time right you
know it's 24 hours in a day and i don't
know how many days i have on the planet
but you know your your time is like a
bank account you can either spend it
this way
or you can spend it this way
that is your choice
this is very very important this is how
you take control of your life
if you are spending your time worrying
about what people are thinking of you
you don't have that time to do something
more important
if you were spending your time puffing
yourself up to i'm the greatest thing in
the world
you don't have that time to go help your
friend with an audition
if you you know what i'm saying so
it's all about
having enough awareness to see how am i
spending my time does it contribute to
my life does it contribute to my
community does it contribute you know